Let me be clear about when it comes to,
the most dangerous party in this country
this is the AfD.
Now I have to see what they demanded.
They want us to get out of the EU.
That would be 1 economic fiasco for Germany,
out From NATO,
we would surrender Putin,
No business tax
more main source of revenue for municipalities,
so no outdoor pools,
no women's shelters,
No daycare centers
for the little people or the little people.
Don't do anything on the right,
Retirement ages are to be high.
Must say quite clearly,
this party makes politics
against the majority of people in the country,
against their worries,
because they benefit from these concerns.
And the AfD is at its core an antisocial party,
that wants to destabilize this country.